thing hit record-breaking levels over
the holiday season according to a new
report consumers spent nearly 212
billion dollars from November 1st to
December 31st and that represents a
three and a half percent increase over
the same period in 2021. despite High
inflation over the past year Adobe
analytics found retailers offered steep
discounts to lure customers this holiday
season it worked all right one thing
that people could do to save money
possibly is re-gift but is that okay to
discuss that we have Sheila Kiest
etiquette expert with us thank you for
being here tonight nice to meet you so
it is tempting to do in fact the old
joke is with fruitcakes you just kind of
re-gift and there's one in the entire
world right is it okay though to re-gift
you know it all depends and the way I
look at it is if it's a family member
who's given you a gift then I would say
no and especially if it's something
they've spent a lot of money on then you
know keep that there do not do not
re-gift it because because you know they
may come around one day and say hey
Sheila where's that lovely gift I gave
you right oh well you know it's uh it
kind of it got broken you know or
whatever so well that could affect
especially you hurt someone's feelings
if they really thought about this gift
and they meant it just for you yeah I
mean if you got you know a duplicate
gift and then you thought well I'll keep
this one because grandma gave this one
to me then maybe you could re-gift it
but again you have to think about all
these things you know people put a lot
of time into purchasing gifts you know
they they think about it and therefore
you know just be a little bit careful
well plus if someone wants to take it
back you probably don't have the gift
Receiver right exactly sure well then
you know maybe keep it for a year and
then donate it to charity or take it to
a Bookshop or something yeah John's
mother she would give me perfume I I
didn't really like it but I kept it so
Grandma's no longer here so I spray it a
little every night again it reminds me
of her memories yeah right that's really
sweet so yeah so little things like that
you mentioned a gift that someone might
follow up on and I think we we've all
been in that awkward situation where you
receive a gift and someone obviously
meant well but it's just not for you for
whatever reason and then they come into
your house and it's expected to be on
display or they're asking if you've used
it yeah what is proper etiquette in that
situation well you can either say you
know what again you know it was lovely
and I had it sitting here and it got
broken or you just keep something you
know because you don't want to offend
your friends yes and I always think that
friendship is the most valuable gift you
can get right so therefore whether you
like it or not hang on to it for a
little bit it's the best advice I can
give so if it's let's say an ugly
display of some sort is it okay to
scramble if you know the Gift Giver is
coming over and put it out on this wet
bar just pull it out and have it sitting
there centerpiece it's perfect you know
and then you can pull it back and put it
away until the next year I think you
bring up an excellent point at the end
of the day it is about relationships it
is yes and you know some people say oh I
give so-and-so a gift and she only gave
me a bunch of flowers well her situation
maybe she could only afford a bunch of
flowers but she was your friend and
therefore she did give you some things
we put too much emphasis on the cost of
things and not the thought that